Let's go through these 1 by 1. So first, x cubed plus 6y squared. We want to
start by finding the degree of each term. So the degree of this first one is 3
and the second term is 2. Since we have exponents of 3 and 2, respectively. 3 is
greater than 2. So this is a third degree polynomial. Next 7 minus 3x plus 8x
cubed y. You have degrees of 0, 1, and 4 since we have 3 plus the invisible 1 on
this y equals 4. 4 is definitely the largest of these three numbers so this
polynomial is of degree 4. So we can do the same thing for the last two
polynomials as well. One interesting thing to note is that the degree of a
polynomial is usually information that comes from just one term in the
expression, the term with the highest degree. But in some cases, like in this
last example, might have more than one term that's of the same degree. So for
example, here we have x squared which is a second degree term and z squared
which is also a second degree term. Having 2 terms of the same degree. Doesn't
change what the highest degree we see here is. We just happen to see that
highest degree twice. We still follow the typical rule and say that this is a
polynomial of degree 2.